(upbeat music)
♪ The name is George Washington
♪ But it's the general to you
♪ Or you can call me President
One, not three or two
♪ And you probably heard a
lot of silly stories 'bout me
♪ But let me lay me down
how raw it really used to me
♪ Got a hip operation,
I got the plantation
♪ Selling the stickiest
shit around the new nation
♪ So come round and find
me if you wanna get high
♪ 'Cause honestly I got the
bombest, I cannot tell a lie
♪ Pick it dry, of
course I'm gonna try
♪ Bag it up and brick
it, then just let 'em buy
♪ And if the Brits wanna come
and take a a piece of the cut
♪ I'll raise a whole fuckin'
army, let 'em see what's what
♪ The king's like,
Yo I gotta get paid
♪ I'm like, tough titty, 'cause
y'all's a whole ocean away
♪ And you can try
to send some ships
♪ To come and make me pay up
♪ But that's an awful long
way just to suck these nuts
♪ You get my
fucking message, son
♪ Take it, Thomas Jefferson
♪ Sell drugs
♪ Run guns
♪ Nail sluts and fuck the law
♪ We're founding fathers,
we're Rushmore shit
♪ And we were all high as balls
♪ The Declaration
of Independence
♪ I wrote so high I'm
surprised it makes sense
♪ But we find these
truths to be self-evident
♪ It goes puff, puff, pass,
the next round you get skipped
♪ Abe Lincoln, I know
what y'all thinking
♪ Greatest president ever
♪ I'll have what he's drinking
♪ Yeah, well see, that's
where you be wrong
♪ 'Cause if you
wanna chill with me
♪ You better go
and grab that bong
♪ Or an apple or a can,
see you do not understand
♪ Faded 20 for a seven 'cause
that's just the way I am
♪ I can see you're having a
little trouble believing me
♪ But check this
letter that I wrote
♪ Recorded down in history, ahem
♪ Two of my favorite things
are sitting on my porch
♪ And smoking a pipe of
that sweet hemp, of course
♪ That's a quote that I wrote
while I was still in office
♪ But enough of
that, I am too high
♪ I have to back up off this
♪ Where's my horse, I think I
need to go and ride him home
♪ I was supposed to leave about
four score and 20 rips ago
♪ You see my hat, I like it,
♪ I kinda think it
looks like a stove
♪ Scratch it, pass up on my time
♪ And let me hit it for the road
♪ Sell drugs
♪ Run guns
♪ Nail sluts and fuck the law
♪ We're founding fathers,
we're Rushmore shit
♪ And we were all high as balls
♪ And don't let 'em
try and tell you
♪ We grew it just for rope
♪ You can check what we wrote
down in our harvest notes
♪ We separated seeds
that we found more potent
♪ In layman's terms,
we were in to get bent
♪ Smokin' out the
continental congress
♪ Everybody's bitches
be like all up on us
♪ Patrick Henry's in the corner
lookin' pretty well spent
♪ Ben Franklin got so high
he forgot to be president
♪ Your girl just said she
never had it hit so good
♪ Smoke so many trees that
my fuckin' teeth turned wood
♪ And if they make a
monument to me when I die
♪ It'll be a giant abstract
joint up in the sky
♪ But you know they
gonna whitewash me
♪ Make up some corny shit
about me chopping cherry trees
♪ It's hard to control a people
if the founders are thugs
♪ So they'll just
teach that I was
♪ All prayers,
puppies, and hugs.
♪ But that just
ain't the way it was
♪ We set this whole place
up with a hell of a buzz
♪ So next time they try and
tell you that the stuff is wrong
♪ Look at a dollar, light a
blunt, fuckin' sing my song
♪ Sell drugs
♪ Run guns
♪ Nail sluts and fuck the law
♪ We're founding fathers,
we're Rushmore shit
♪ And we were all high as balls
♪ The Declaration
of Independence
♪ I wrote so high, I'm
surprised it makes sense
♪ But we find these
truths to be self-evident
♪ It goes puff, puff, pass,
the next round you get skipped
♪ We're the founders
and we found this
♪ And we found it
with some cannabis
♪ We're the founders
and we found this
♪ And we found it
with some cannabis
♪ Mount Rushmore crew
♪ Stone monument to
some monumental stoners
♪ Ha-Ha!
♪ G. Washington, T.
Jefferson, and A. Lincoln
♪ And fuck that other guy
♪ Calvin Coolidge,
whoever the fuck
♪ We history